und jetzt kommen wir zum bürgerfest
chaos cooper test soll nämlich künftig
drei euro kosten abrechnen sollen dass
die kassen ärzte doch darüber ist ein
heftiger streit zwischen dem
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach und
den kassen ärzten entbrannt die das
nicht abrechnen wollen seit dem
wochenende sei der streit nun beigelegt
sagt lauterbach jetzt eine talkshow kam
er mit den also kassen ärzten gesprochen
selbstverständlich im vorfeld und dass
auch geprüft zunächst einmal die kasse
aber die sagen jetzt immer hans nicht
die kassen sich vereinigung wird das
machen und also ich hab schon also am
wochenende mit der also mit dem kbv-chef
kassen darüber gesprochen wir treffen
uns auch jetzt am anfang der woche wenn
jemand sagt ich gehe abends in ein
konzert ich will mich jetzt testen
lassen drei euro das wird gemacht
unterschreibt das verlassen was darauf
wird nehmen die bürger hier beim wort
und das ist daher relativ unbürokratisch
und die kasseler die bundesvereinigung
kann sich dem auch nicht einfach
entziehen sondern sind der aufgabe das
abzurechnen wir haben ein recht darauf
dass wir das so einfach machen für die
kv wie möglich das werden wir tun das
haben wir vorbereitet aber es bleibt
dabei die bürger test bleiben es kommt
zu dieser selbstbeteiligung das können
wir nicht anders handhaben wir haben für
die tests mehr ausgeben was für alle
impfstoffe und wir können auch die
kassenärztliche vereinigung hier nicht
aus der pflicht nehmen sie sind
verpflichtet das zu machen dabei bleibt
es auch dabei bleibt es auch lauterbach
sagt also klipp und klar die
kassenärztliche vereinigung die wird das
waren ja aber stimmt das denn fakt ist
es gibt keine einigung die
kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung der
eta hat eigens die pelle die länder per
mail informiert und lauterbachs aussagen
nicht zugestimmt es gibt also keine
einigung und darüber müssen wir sprechen
mit bild-reporter julius bilden bei uns
im studio beim blick schön dass du hier
bist nicht mehr so richtig durch der
eine sagt man hat sich geeinigt die
andere sagen stimmt überhaupt gar nicht
und alle bürgerinnen und bürger stehen
da und fragen sich was denn nun bringt
es ein bisschen licht ins dunkel also
das spannende ist laut hat gestern abend
klipp und klar gesagt die kassen erste
machen dass das klingt so als ob
irgendwie ein machtwort gesprochen
worden wäre oder irgend eine einigung
gefunden wurde spannend ist aber das
eigentliche treffen um einen kompromiss
zu finden wie man die lösung jetzt
findet war eben gerade erst um 12.30
haben sich lauterbach und kassen zoo
chef dr andreas gassen getroffen um da
einen kompromiss zu finden wir wollen
natürlich auch rein was denn die lösung
sein soll denn die denn da kvs gibt es
17 kassenärztliche vereinigung und die
bundeskasse den vereinigungen haben
allesamt gesagt ja nicht wir wollen das
nicht machen sagt wir können einfach
nicht abrechnen weil wir als
hauptsächlich erstmal ärzte haben gar
nicht die mittel um zu überprüfen wenn
du hast du jetzt darum geht es uns sagt
ich besuche meine großmutter heute abend
kann ich dann überprüfen hast du eine
großmutter wie alt ist dies die gesund
und wird er werden nämlich falschangaben
gemacht und wir haben erlebt dass
milliardenbeträge missbraucht wurden in
all diesen stellt fest sind drin von
unserem steuergeld wie könnte denn da
jetzt die lösung aussehen was könnte da
jetzt besprochen worden sein die
entscheidende frage ist wer haftet wenn
am ende schon gemacht wird die
kassenärzte sagen wir können nicht
überprüfen weil wir sind ja angewiesen
auf die dutzenden schnelltest hatte die
uns dazu liefen jetzt wäre die frage
kann man die testzentren in die pflicht
nehmen sagen ihr müsst sozusagen
wirklich nachweisen dass die angaben
stimmen oder er muss aber eine der
minister dafür hat er selbst eine
talkshow gesagt naja wir vertrauen
darauf die bürger man muss da gar nicht
so viel prüfen aber wenn denn dann der
große betrug kommt möchte ich mal
denjenigen sehen der sagt na ja wir
hatten noch vertrauen die bürger jetzt
halt eben ein paar millionen euro weg so
leicht funktioniert es eben nicht und
das ist eben die entscheidende frage wer
haftet
davon hängt die abrechnung ab also es
ist schon wieder muss man sagen nervig
das ganze corona thema und das ganze
test thema was glaubst du wie geht das
am ende für uns aus wird der
gesundheitsminister sich durchsetzen
können und die kassen ärzte müssen
irgendwie schauen wie sie das regeln
oder wird es uns bürgern irgendwie
einfach gemacht oder müssen wir da
selber am ende hinter mit einem riesen
nachweislich geburtstage geburts gebucht
der großmutter funktion gewalt und das
ist sie noch gibt und dass sie in
oberursel wohnt also wie soll das gehen
also die kasse erst die
bundesvereinigung und die kassen
vereinigung sind ja eine körperschaft
des öffentlichen rechts diesen jetzt
nicht irgendwie so eine
privatvorstellung ein verein der sagen
kann nun machen wir nicht da gibt es
schon gewisse pflichten sozialgesetzbuch
ob der minister die dazu zwingen kann am
ende das ist so ein bisschen wie offene
frage ist wie wahrscheinlich niemand mit
konzerttickets test hätte umgehen am
ende man wird sich sehr wahrscheinlich
auf einen kompromiss für beide seiten
gesichtswahrend ist
einigen können oder auch müssen
entscheidend ist aber wir brauchen wir
diese bürger tests überhaupt noch in
dieser menge und masse
lassen sagt nein gassen sagt dass die
sogar unsinnig sind und
infektionsgefahren wieder was was ändern
noch und was darüber verraten das sagen
einige experten lauterbach will daran
unbedingt festhalten weil er die
selektions ketten unterbrechen möchte
das komische daran ist dass der
expertenrat der bundesregierung dieses
gremium wacht christian drosten drin
sitzt gesagt hat wir müssen langsam weg
kommen von diesen ketten unterbrechen
containment heißt es einfach fachbegriff
weitergehen zu medikation und zur
schadensbegrenzung im großen und ganzen
man sich anguckt wer wirklich krank die
schützen wir gezielt den stellen wir
auch die test kostenlos zur verfügung
und alle anderen jungen menschen wir
erleben kann alle wahnsinnig viele
infektionen im umfeld die alle irgendwie
glimpflich ausgehen einfach das normale
leben sozusagen zurückgeben und corona
und nikon zu irgendwie ja in einer ende
zu führen es wäre wirklich schön wenn
wir das thema nun endlich beenden
könnten vielen dank julius für deine
einordnung jetzt in diesem schweren
thema